before I actually start on make a quick
note they give you a diagram they give
you a diagram but please please PLEASE I
want you to get your ruler out and draw
your own version of the diagram in your
book it doesn't have to be huge it
doesn't have to be beautiful but it does
have to be big enough that you could
work with it and importantly then you
can label things on there okay the
reason why is because drawing a diagram
is one of the best ways to understand
how something works how the diagram will
fits together like a puzzle here's what
we got what kind of shape is this it's a
parallelogram
it is a quadrilateral but because we
know more about it then it just has four
sides right I can say it's a particular
kind of shape how did you know it was
parallelogram what puppies did you see
yep
yeah fantastic these are business idea
and these opposite sides here two pairs
parallel sides and that's what makes a
parallelogram fantastic now being that
we know it's a parallelogram we can use
everything that we already know about
parallelograms to proof things about so
here's a first start at their first line
of they've asked us to fill it in you
got these two angles here right and what
they do is they sit between these
parallel lines can you see that assumed
to be parallel it and when you looked at
angles last year you seven you would
have learned that these two angles
they're both inside the parallel light
right they're both inside so we call
these because they're both inside anyone
ano KO interior fantastic in fact that
literally means Co interior literally
needs both curve like if you Kurt have
it means two people living in the same
house right and interior means on the
inside what's the opposite by the way
what's what's when you're on the outside
excellent right so there's interior or
exterior here
they're both inside so what I've got is
Co interior angles and the comment area
it goes up on parallel lives I've run
out of space
now I'm actually going to add something
in here that the they don't have a spot
for on your textbook but that's why we
do it together come to your angles on
parallel line what's special about Co
interior a was right okay fantastic they
add up to 180 degrees we have a big long
fancy where that starts with s that
these are Sam thing
supplementary you can save either of
those in your reason over here
you can either say Co interior angles
are parallel lines add at 180 that it'd
be perfect or you can say that coming to
your angles on power lines myself a bit
true I like that word so I'm going to
use that both of them be the same thing
so both of them are fine okay okay now
from that you can see and again if
you've got another color there we really
hope for the highlight mystery I've got
two things here that are kind of matched
together two things that are matched
together I've got a mathematical
statement something equals something
else
okay and what I've got paired with it is
the reason why it's true this is kind of
like your evidence right like a lawyer
gets up and he says I think that such as
such as guilty I think he has to make a
case oh yeah okay that's true they have
oh yes right well prosecutor lawyers
okay so I've got a reason here which is
a geometric shape treason a geometric
reason so these two things are always
paired up together you got a statement
can reason statement reason now off of
this statement I only need to do one
thing to both besides it's an equation
right to get a by itself what should I
do both sides
just heads up time ago so doesn't send
it yeah what can I do to both sides of
this equation so I'll just get a bye
it's so yeah okay yet so I'm I don't
want the aim with something else I want
to get this seventy over the other side
so the way I do that is I would subtract
set me from here you got to do both
sides don't you okay so I'm going to do
this once I've subtracted semi from here
just disappears and once you subtract 70
from this you get 110 very good okay
fantastic so remember what I was trying
to do I was trying to find the unknown
pronumerals and I found one of them
thumbs up now I'll do my other one it's
be the great thing here is I'm starting
a new statement a new mathematical
statement these kind of is like a
invisible dotted line between these like
you don't the staffers like the
invisible minds car will pass so these
two are never started you think they're
different new mathematical statement and
we don't have a new geometric reason
what is B equal to can anyone see you
look think about all those properties
you know what do you reckon well okay
now B is equal to 17 that does look
right but why is it true because it is
it is there's at least a couple of
reasons I can think of yeah okay
fantastic so by the way thank you it's
okay get to you thinking you can see
this one of Bowness reasons for white
drawer and diagram cuz you can scroll
all over your a diagram that would you
kind of do in the textbook okay so you
can see B and 17 are opposite one of the
properties we've learned about the
parallelogram is that opposite angles in
a parallelogram are equal
by the way it is helpful to mention that
it's ops angles in a parallelogram
because looking at our shapes there are
loads of shapes where the opposite
angles are equal I'm cat one two three
right only these guys have opposite
angles are equal so that's why I
mentioned in my geometric reasons that
backs up my mathematical statement I
give all of the facts that ultimately
make sense okay fantastic so there are
three things I want you to take away
from this on two things really number
one please draw a diagram even if they
give you one please draw your own one so
you can scroll all over and label and
number two always pair up a statement
and a reason statement and a reason you
should always see this to go